Instructor: Let's
look at a couple more examples
of when you would actually use
destructuring in the real world.
This is not just when you want
to grab variables out of an
object or out of an array.
Let's take a look right here
where we're building an
application for a wrestling
application. In wrestling, they
are tag teaming. I don't really
know that much about wrestling,
but I know that there's one guy
in the ring and one guy on the
side. Let's create let inRing = "
The Hulkster" and we'll say let
onSide = "The Rock". I'm not
sure if these guys ever wrestled
together, but it seems feasible.
They need to tag team each other.
What happens when you need to
switch? The Rock's going in the
ring and the Hulkster is going
on the side. How did you do that
before? If you do this, inRing
is Hulk Hogan. If you say inRing =
onSide, now inRing is The Rock,
but then also onSide is also The
Rock and we've lost the Hulkster
altogether. How do we
actually get around that? The
way we used to be able to do it
is we would make a temp variable.
We'd say var temp = inRing, and
then you'd say inRing = onSide,
and onSide = temp. They're
totally switched now, and then
you would delete your actual
temp variable. That's really
hard to follow. That's hard to
look at, especially someone
coming after six months of not
working on this code, trying to
understand what's going on.
With destructuring, we can just
swap them. We can just take an
array and say inRing, onSide =
onSide, inRing. What? What
that's going to do is it's going
to create an array of onSide,
inRing and immediately
destructure them into the
opposite variables. Now you
see why I use let instead of
const here, because we're
actually updating the values of
these variables. Let's take
these inRing, onSide variables,
console.log it beforehand, and
then also console.log it right
after we do it. Hulk Hogan, The
Rock and then The Rock, Hulk
Hogan. They've totally swapped
themselves, without the need for
a third swap temp variable.